RICHARD GINGRAS: Welcome
to Authors at Google.
I'm Richard Gingras,
and today we're
here with Yukari Itawani Kane.
YUKARI IWATANI
KANE: Iwatani Kane.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Iwatani Kane.
I read it wrong.
I have a typo.
Who's talking to us here today
about her recently published
book, "Haunted Empire,
Apple after Steve Jobs."
I think probably all
of us would agree
that probably the most
fascinating question
in the world of tech
the last couple of years
is indeed just that,
is how will Apple
survive the death of
its legendary founder.
But I'm sure everyone
in this room,
after just a couple
of minutes' thought,
can come up with a very
thoughtful and glib answer
to that question.
But Yukari here actually,
you spent almost two years
looking at this question, and
I thank you for doing that.
But let me first give you
a little bit of background,
and then we'll get
into the discussion.
Yukari has been writing about
the tech industry for over 15
years.
And as a reporter for the
"Wall Street Journal,"
she covered Apple
during the last years
of Steve Jobs' reign.
Kane is best known for
her in depth analysis
and scoops, among which include
the news about Steve Jobs'
top secret liver transplant,
the launch of the initial iPad,
the launch of the
iPhone on Verizon.
Her stories have often included
the off beat as well as
the hilarious-- a fun piece
on a 15-year-old iPhone
hacker and a story
on iPad couture that
became the subject of a
fabulous Steven Colbert rant.
You can still find it
on YouTube somewhere.
In 2011, she was named
as the Gerald Loeb Award
finalist as part of a
WSJ team for a series
on internet privacy.
Among her peers, she
developed a reputation
as the recipient of
controlled leaks from Apple--
and we may talk
about that-- even
becoming the
subject of a segment
on NPR's "On the Media."
According to Yukari, the
truth is considerably less
interesting.
All of her scoops
and stories came
from painstaking
reporting and vetting.
So I'd like to actually
start by going back
to the basics with you
and your career, which
is, what caused you to become a
journalist in the first place?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
It's interesting
because I grew up in the '80s,
and I'm originally from Japan.
And I moved back and forth
between the US and Japan
because of my dad's job.
And the '80s was when
there was a lot of tension
between the two countries,
if you remember,
with the automobile
industry and et cetera.
And I just saw a lot
of miscommunication
and misunderstanding going on.
And I thought to
myself, well, I could
help explain things
to each other.
And that's what peaked my
initial interest in journalism.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
given that you've
been doing this for a
while, and you've just
completed this book,
I think one thing that
would be interesting to
explore before we get
into the actual substance
of it is a bit more
of behind the scenes
how you do these things.
So if you could kind of
give us just a little bit
of a window on the
process you went through
in producing the book.
And I'd even start at the very
beginning, in the sense of,
what was your thesis
going in, and how close
was the end result
to that thesis?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Well, my thesis going in
was completely different.
I covered Apple during
Steve's last three years.
And if you remember,
it also coincided
with this really strong
period of growth at Apple.
They were pulling in triple
digit profits and revenue
growth.
And I wanted to tell
the story of how Apple
went from bankruptcy
to the success
that it became-- near
bankruptcy to the success,
focusing not on
Steve, but on the team
and how it actually
really came together,
rather than the myth of
Steve having done everything.
And that was the
book that I proposed
and sold and began working on.
And a year into the
process, I realized
that history is not as relevant
and interesting anymore,
and that what
everybody really was
interested in was what was
going on now without Steve,
and how Apple was going to
deal with this transition.
And that the question
was interesting
from not just Apple's story,
but from a much broader
perspective.
Because the story
is actually really
about what happens to an empire
when it loses its emperor.
And it's a story that you
see in governments as well
as companies and in
different situations.
And this was
happening in business,
and it was happening
right under my nose.
And I had a chance
to have a front seat
and be witness to it.
And so I did a complete shift
and started from scratch.
Not really from scratch
because by that time,
I had done a ton of interviews
about how Apple rebuilt itself.
And so that ended up
being a really good basis
to figure out what was changing.
Because of course,
you can't really
understand what's changing until
you understand how things were.
But one of the first
things I did was I
booked a three-week
trip to Asia.
Because so much
of Apple's success
had to do with its operations
and the supply chain in Asia,
and so much of the
growth that was coming
was from Asia as well.
And I wanted to
see it for myself.
And John Ryan, who's sitting
there, was my host in Taiwan
at the time, where I
spent about 10 days.
A lot of the suppliers
are headquartered there,
so the factory
workers are in China,
but the suppliers and the
management is in Taiwan.
And you get a really
great sense of what
the strategy and the thinking
is and how things have changed.
But I tend to favor
face-to-face meetings
and talking to people who
know pieces of information
firsthand.
It's how I got my
scoops at the "Journal."
I think you don't have
to get the guy that
knows everything
about everything.
You just need to get the
guy who knows a little bit
about something, but
knows it firsthand.
And then you talk to
enough of those people,
and you piece it together,
and you get a picture.
And so I talked to
almost 200 people.
I also don't trust
anybody else as much
as I trust myself
and my own judgment.
So wherever I can see things
for myself, I like to go there.
So I went to Europe to talk to
a lot of Jonathan Ive's designer
friends and colleagues
from the past.
I went to China, went
to the factory gates
at Foxconn at Shenzhen, spent
some time talking to a factory
worker that I still
keep in touch with.
I also talked to others through
the Twitter-like messaging
and things like that.
But I like to meet
them whenever I can.
The other thing that I did was
I went to Robertsdale, Alabama,
where Tim Cook is from,
to really understand
his background.
Because he is such a private
and mysterious person.
And so I wanted to
understand it for myself.
I grew up in the East
Coast, but I was up north.
So part of what I thought
I needed to understand
was the southern
culture as well.
So that was my reporting.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So I think
when most of us think of Apple
and think of Jobs, we think
of the product vision.
We think it his
intense attention
to detail in building products.
And one other thing
that surprised me
when I read the
book, in a good way,
was how much focus you
put on the supply chain.
And I can understand
its relevance.
One, we're seeing interesting
political problems and problems
of labor management and so on
and so forth come out of that.
They're certainly
interesting threads
in terms of Apple's innovation
in material science.
And of course, it's what
Tim Cook's expertise is.
But what drove you to go there?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Part of it was certainly
because these factory conditions
were getting so much scrutiny.
This was shortly after the "New
York Times" series went out.
And I've been in
journalism long enough
to know that how you
characterize things really
is such a personal thing.
And I'd spent some time in Asia
as a correspondent as well,
and I know how the realities
in certain countries
can be understood
differently in others.
So I wanted to make that
decision for myself.
But also because so
much of Apple's business
is reliant on the supply chain.
Foxconn and Apple kind
of grew up together,
and they've gotten big together.
And I think the way
their relationship works
is an incredibly important
part of Apple's success.
And when that starts
breaking down,
it has profound implications.
The other thing is that I
think what gets lost here
is that Foxconn is just as
much of a dynamic company
as Apple is, arguably.
It has a very dynamic
CEO, very ambitious.
Has also really done the
impossible to get his company
at the scale and size it is.
And it is technically,
because of the relationship,
it is a supplier to Apple.
But it is in no way
subservient to Apple.
And I wanted to
really understand
where they're coming from
and what their interests are.
Because those motivations,
when they start changing,
that has profound
implications for Apple.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I think that
was certainly interesting
in not only the, I think, the
public perception of Apple
in terms of how the
products are produced,
but also one of the
things you surfaced
was how the suppliers
are in a sense
now learning how to fight
back against Google,
against Apple, which obviously
raises its own set of issues.
But let me, if I can, take
us back to Jobs's role.
I worked at Apple
in the '90s, but I
worked at Apple in
the in-between period
when Steve wasn't there, when
the product line expanded
from three different Macs to
five different product lines.
Every division had
its own product line.
It was rather run amok.
My own sense is that one
of his greatest strengths
was, in a sense, as
an editor of making
the hard decisions about what
survived and went to market
and what did not.
And frankly, my
own perception is
that's probably one of
their biggest challenges
going forward, is how do you
decide, with all of these very
creative people in
their workforce,
all competing for attention,
all with great ideas,
winnowing down to the
one, two, or three that
actually should see the market.
What did you learn about that?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I think
that's absolutely true,
and it's the way
people who've worked
for him have characterized
his strengths as well.
I had a really
interesting conversation
with a former Apple
senior manager.
This was a couple months ago.
And we were talking about
what's changed today.
And one of the things he said
that I thought was interesting
was he said,
everybody's wondering
who has the vision
at Apple today.
And he said, the
problem isn't vision.
There's lots of vision at Apple.
The problem is
that there are now
thousands of different
visions and not just one.
And that's Apple's challenge.
And that really rang true to me.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Yeah.
But also, in fairness,
I would actually
suggest that some of the
challenges they're facing
are indeed of Job's own making.
One I would point to is
his absolute insistence
over the years of maintaining
the proprietary unlicensed
nature of the platform, such
that even where they introduced
the iPhone and quickly
dominated the space.
But obviously, that's
been eaten away.
It's hard to compete with
40 producers of phones
working off of other OSes
versus licensing off of yours.
Some would look
at that in a sense
as a squandered opportunity.
Do you think there's
likely to be change
in that regard at
Apple, or are you
hearing the same sort of
adherence to his philosophy?
YUKARI IWATANI
KANE: People think
that Apple's
starting to open up.
I think there was an
announcement at WWEC
last week where they
were going to-- the home
kit was going to work
with third party products.
My feeling is that whatever
they do, if they change,
it won't be enough.
Because it's just so entrenched
in their culture to not
want to be open.
The secrecy is part of
it, and their inability
to share even things
that they need to.
And I think that's something
that's so deep in Apple's DNA
that I'm not sure--
they may try,
but I would guess that it's
not going to be enough.
Whatever they do, it'll
just come a little bit more
slowly than it should, or it
would be a little bit more
limiting than it should.
And those are the little
things that ultimately
create a Sony type situation.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I recall--
and again, I was there
in a very bad period for Apple,
and probably the market share
was 6%.
But it was such
an insular culture
that frankly, you could
live inside the Apple world
and not even think that Windows
existed was how severe they
were inured from
the outside world.
Obviously, that
can be problematic
and has proven to
be problematic.
But one thing I learned was
that I had thought with iTunes,
this was a big opportunity for
them in a sense to break out.
And they made iTunes
available on Windows
to stimulate iPod
sales, I should say.
And that was actually something
that Steve was not in favor of
and had to be basically
forced by his team to do.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Yeah, the story I got
was that Steve was
very much against it.
He wanted to keep it just
to the Mac ecosystem.
And essentially his entire
senior management team
at that time laid on the tracks
and convinced him otherwise.
And it was one of
those situations where
he was like, fine, do
you what you want to do.
But if you screw up,
if it doesn't work out,
then it's your head.
But they believed
strongly enough.
And of course, now that it's
successful, as everything else,
Steve claims credit.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Though, in a sense,
it's hard not to think
that his push back on that
did not have a cultural impact.
Because I still have a
hard time looking at Apple
as being as dedicated
to cloud development
as many would suggest
the market would demand.
And I don't know how much of
that is sort of reticence or--
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
I mean, I think
the cloud-- Apple's culture
just seems to work against,
be so contrary to what great
cloud software demands.
And I think it's a weakness.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Yeah.
So in reading the book
and going back over how
Apple has been covered
in the last few years,
it's hard not to escape
the fact that the brand has
been tarnished a bit.
I mean, the fact that Apple has
twice in that period of time
actually come out with
public apologies about one
matter or another, which is
something that he certainly
would not have done.
I mean, this is a company that
has managed the press more
tightly than probably any
other American media company.
And there too, I suspect
there's a change in philosophy.
Or is it just the fact
that Tim and others there
don't have the same ability
to, in a sense, reality
distort that Steve had?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: We've all
known what a great marketer
Steve is, or was.
I don't think I myself
realized how important
that was to Apple's success.
Because I do think that Apple's
lost control of its narrative.
And it's because
Steve isn't there.
Steve inspired people in a way
that just defied rationality.
I mean, people were inspired
by whatever Steve said,
whether it was promises
of things to come
or the fabulousness of something
that Apple has released.
And I was in so many
launch events for something
where he's announcing
something, and the cheers
are enormous, the
whistles, everything.
And you feel like,
oh my god, Apple's
done this really great thing.
And then you go
back to your desk,
and you're like, oh,
well, wait a second.
Google had this already.
[LAUGHTER]
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: It's
not that interesting.
It's a cosmetic fix.
But he got people really worked
up and excited about things.
And Apple really doesn't
have anybody today
that can inspire that kind
of irrational exuberance
about the company.
And when you listen to
what they're saying,
they're actually saying
a lot of the same things
that Steve said.
I mean, they're still
operating by the same playbook.
They talk about these
amazing things to come.
And the wording is very
similar to what Steve said.
And so they're trying to do what
he did, but it just falls flat.
And I think that's just the
difference in who is saying it.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
It almost speaks
to the charisma, the
showmanship, as it were.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Yeah,
and it's not just the impact
that it has to
consumers, but it's
about his ability to inspire the
employees, his executive team,
his shareholders, the board.
When you think
about it, Apple-- I
mean, if you are the CEO of a
company of so many constituents
that you have to respond
to-- the suppliers.
I mean, the suppliers
are working for you,
but everybody knows that no
matter how much money you pay,
if their hearts not in it, it's
just not going to be as good.
And so when the message is
a little bit less powerful,
there are a lot of ramifications
for all those different people.
RICHARD GINGRAS: By the way,
get your questions ready.
I'll be turning to the audience
for questions in a minute.
Would love to hear them.
So let's go to your
bottom line quickly.
So what is your sense?
Is Apple going to stay great?
Are we going to see-- are they
going to weather the storm,
or is this in a sense the
waning of Apple's significance
as a consumer
electronics company?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I
mean, it's a tricky question
because it depends
on how you define it.
From a revenue and
profit standpoint,
Apple will be making money for
a really long time to come.
But if you are talking
about Apple's ability
to create the waves and
innovate and come out
with game-changing devices,
I just don't see it.
I mean, I think Apple
could stay a good company.
But the insanely great
company that it's been,
I'm just not sure
that's possible.
And if you look back
in history, Apple
is going through a
lot of the same things
that a lot of empires
have gone before them.
And it feels a little bit like--
I call it business physics,
but there's a force that
as you get more successful,
wants to bring
you to the center.
And that's the challenge
that Apple is facing.
We'll see.
I mean, they've defied
the odds before.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Yeah, and there's
an interesting
bridge from there.
They recently
acquired Beats, which
means that Dr. Dre and
Jimmy Iovine are going
to be wearing badges and taking
the bus down from San Francisco
to work at Apple every day.
But interestingly, an
ex-Googler, Paul Buccheit,
upon that announcement suggested
that with the savvy of Beats
that Apple will be able
to design wearables
for the mass market
that Google could not.
Which frankly, I
kind of chuckled at
because there's
no question, Beats
was successful in
getting a lot of people
to wear soup cans
back around their ears
with the Beats headphones again.
I'm not sure if
that's the secret
of getting into the mass market.
But what's your sense of
the Beats acquisition?
How is that going to work?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
It's a great question.
I wrote an analysis
about it as well.
And it is a puzzling
acquisition to me.
There's the thought that--
$3 billion is a lot of money.
Apple developed the
iPhone, I think,
on a couple hundred
million dollars.
So what does Beats offer that
they couldn't do themselves?
From an aesthetic perspective--
I think the financials,
maybe there's a way that
the financials make sense.
But from a larger
sense, aesthetically
the Beats aesthetic
is completely
opposite of Apple's aesthetic.
It's a company that has made
money built on marketing,
not as much on-- I
don't think they're
known for the quality
of their headphones.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Right.
They're a marketing company.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
And I don't know
if this is true.
People have also told me
that their headphones are
more popular outside of
the US than inside the US.
And the young people
outside of the US
buy them because
it's a way for them
to connect to the
American culture.
I have no idea how
that adds to Apple.
And people have talked about
how Apple is buying Beats cool.
And if Apple, which
has defined cool--
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Has defined cool.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
For the last 15
years is buying
Beats for its cool,
then they're really in a lot
more trouble than we think.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I think
that is the conclusion.
I mean, when thinking about
it with regard to Jobs,
the only phrase I could think of
was turning over in his grave.
It seems quite hard
to believe that that
would have been something he
would have been supportive of.
But let's turn to questions.
AUDIENCE: Do you think Steve
Jobs had any other choices
besides Cook in terms of--
I mean, from your book,
it seemed like they were--
RICHARD GINGRAS:
I thought you were
going to say besides dying.
Reality distortion
field to its ultimate.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I've
said this a couple of times.
I actually think the
more interesting one
was Ron Johnson.
It was actually a name
that was whispered
by a couple of my sources.
Nobody's going to say it
on the record or out loud.
But I heard it from a
couple different people
when the leadership
change was announced
that it should have been Ron.
But the more I think about
it, the more I agree.
Because Ron Johnson was
the head of Apple Retail.
And he was the architect
of the Apple Stores.
And Steve was involved in the
Apple Stores in the extent that
he cared about the look
and feel of the stores,
but the culture that was built
and the success is really
Ron's.
It operated fairly
autonomously within Apple.
And he's an incredibly
charismatic guy.
I have a ton of respect for him.
I know he went to JC Penney
and didn't do too well,
but I think a lot of that
had to do with JC Penney.
In terms of what
he did at Apple,
he was a very
impressive executive.
And he would have had
the ability to inspire,
and he would have
certainly had the vision.
The worst thing that people have
said about Ron that I've heard
is that he enjoys his money.
But what executive doesn't?
And I think it goes back
to Steve, his unwillingness
to share the spotlight.
And a lot of executives
left, eventually
ended up leaving,
because of that.
And it was the
weakness in his genius.
I share a story in my
book about the first time
he was diagnosed with cancer.
And when he announces
it, the stock rose,
I think by only 1% or 2%.
And when he heard about it,
he was really disappointed,
and he was like, that's it?
And so he was
definitely a guy who
may not have wanted his
private life probed, but wanted
Apple to be about him.
And I think that's
part of the challenge
that Apple faces today.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well, it had
to be an internal candidate.
There was no way they
were going to bring
in someone from the outside.
And so you're really left
with few possibilities.
I mean, there's Eddy Cue.
There's Ives, though
I'm not sure about that.
Obviously Scott Forstall
was not going to be a--
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Yeah.
I mean, as part of
the book, I talk
about this-- there's a
Harvard professor called
Gautam Mukunda.
And interestingly, Apple brought
him in to Apple University
to talk about his
leadership theories.
But one of the things,
his ideas about executives
who rise up within the
system and are chosen,
and then ones who
just are chosen
despite all the odds, and it
was just a complete anomaly.
And one of the things he says
is that those executives have
a high failure rate,
but when they succeed,
it's just tremendous.
And Steve falls into
that because there
was no way he would have
returned to Apple if it
wasn't near bankruptcy.
And the other
category, of course,
is the executive that
rises within the company.
And for that executive,
it's very hard
to think outside the box
because the entire reason
they were chosen is because
they fit so well in the culture,
and they were doing so
well in the culture.
And those executives, there's
not that much difference.
If you look at the top three
candidates that arise out
of that, there's not that
much difference between them.
And the likelihood
that they're going
to do something
completely out of the box
is very rare,
although you can still
have very good executives.
And so Tim Cook would
be typical of that.
And I think in that sense,
yeah, it's a good question.
I mean I, think Tim Cook
was the obvious choice,
given all of the realities.
But I'm not sure we can
expect a Steve Jobs.
RICHARD GINGRAS: What's your
take on Ives, for that matter?
He's a mysterious character.
He only appears in videos
and product introductions.
What is he hiding?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Well, Apple has
been trying to portray him as
Steve's visionary successor.
I think for me, one
of the things that we
need to be aware of is that
he's an industrial designer.
And he's probably one of the
greatest industrial designers
of his generation,
if not the greatest.
But he's an industrial
designer, and so what
makes him a genius in
that is that he cares
about the appearance, and
he pushes the boundaries
of aesthetics
without consideration
of how things work
or can work inside.
And so he is getting more
and more responsibility.
And what I worry
there is that we're
going to end up with beautiful
products that work just
a little bit less well because
he cares more about how things
look.
RICHARD GINGRAS: But he's
lost his editor in a sense.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: And
he's lost his editor.
And anybody who does
creative work knows that,
no matter how
brilliant you are, you
miss something when you
don't have an editor.
And so Apple's successes
happened because of the team,
the partnership between
Steve and Johnny.
And one good question is,
who's Johnny's partner now?
And I don't see anybody.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
And importantly,
who can push back on him?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Who can push back.
Yeah.
I mean, I just don't
see Tim doing that.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Right.
And how about Eddy Cue, because
he's really the only other?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I don't
think Eddy has the authority.
He just made senior vice
president a couple years ago.
And his area is iTunes
and deal making,
and I don't see him
being super involved
in product development.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Questions?
AUDIENCE: So if we
look at stock market
as the aggregate view of the
overall society on the prospect
of a company, or their
sentiment about it,
over the past
three months alone,
Apple has added about $120
billion to their market cap.
That's more than Twitter,
Netflix, Tesla, and Yahoo
put together, like
their entire worth.
So where is this
sentiment coming from?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Apple's strongest base
has always been the Apple
fans and the support
of people who love
their products.
I've been covering business and
financial news for a long time,
and the way the stock market
moves is psychological as well.
And so Apple is helped
by a lot of people
who want to think
about the best of them.
I mean, the market is
also doing generally well.
And from a profit and
revenue standpoint,
Apple will make money
for a long time to come.
I mean, their pie is
so big at this point.
In some ways, it probably makes
sense to put a bet on Apple
from that perspective.
I mean, the way
I look at it, I'm
looking at it from
a much higher plane,
and just what happens to--
Apple's own definition
of a vision has been to make
insanely great products that
change the world.
And what is happening to
that is more of my interest.
And regardless of whether
they pull through or not,
there's no question that
this period, this last couple
of years and maybe a
couple more years to come,
is a major event in
Apple's corporate history.
And it presents a
lot of challenges.
One, because of the
transition, but also because it
grew so fast and has all of a
sudden gone from an underdog
to a dominant company.
And in many ways, it still
has that underdog culture.
And so there are
growing pains from that.
And those are the stories that I
was interested in and following
and thinking about.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well, I think
the key point there is that
obviously, in the fast-changing
world of technology,
is are they going to be the next
great new entries of products
on their part?
What's the big new
invention that's
going to carry them
forward, or inventions
that are going to
carry them forward?
Wall Street doesn't typically
do a very good job of--
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: And I think
also financially, the cracks
start appearing
long before you see
any cracks in the financials.
I used to cover Sony
before I covered Apple.
And Sony was doing well
for a really long time
before it started
going off of a cliff.
And when you look back at
where things went wrong,
it started to happen when
things looked really, really
good for them.
RICHARD GINGRAS: And also with
the loss of their founder.
YUKARI IWATANI
KANE: Yeah, exactly.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Morita.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
As someone on the
communications team,
I actually have a question
about the process a little bit.
First, did Apple
participate in this book?
And second, even covering
them for the past three years
or however long
you've covered them,
how have you worked with
that culture of secrecy
and not sort of talking a lot?
How have you had to change
your reporting style
to get the scoops and figure
out how to work with them?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: It's a
lot of guerrilla reporting.
In answer to your
first question,
I did keep Apple in the
loop for a long time.
I told them first when I
started working on the book.
I told them when I
sold the book and kept
them updated for about
a year and a half,
until they officially
declined to cooperate.
At which point, I decided
that my obligations were over.
But it was well
into-- I explained
when the direction
of the book changed.
I was also sending emails
to Tim Cook regularly.
When I went to China
and I came back,
I sent him an email
with some of my thoughts
and invited him to
correct me where I'm wrong
and things like that.
They didn't respond.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Did he engage?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
He didn't engage.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Which was
expected because Apple doesn't
typically cooperate
on these books.
But it just makes
you work harder.
And I don't think--
I actually have
come to believe
that I was helped
by their lack of cooperation
because it allowed me to stay
independent in my thinking,
and it made me work harder.
And also because
after Steve died,
Apple's executives have been
out in the media so much.
And their message is
pretty consistent.
Nobody ever gets anything that
Apple didn't intend to say.
And so I felt that even if
I had gotten interviews,
all they would have said
was the same thing they've
said everywhere
else, and I already
had that because it
was on the record.
And so I had that,
and then I was
in addition able to get
this 360 degree view.
I was talking to people who
worked-- with regards to Tim
Cook, for example, I
was talking to people
who worked for Tim Cook,
who Tim Cook worked for.
I talked to his school
friends from Robertsdale,
teachers, professors.
It just challenges
you to go deep.
AUDIENCE: How do you convince
them to talk with you?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: People
like to tell stories.
The difference with book writing
and newspaper article writing
is that when I was
at the "Journal,"
it was much more of a
challenge because I wanted
to know what the next
product looked like.
I mean, I was asking people
to share corporate secrets.
And that's a much
more challenging thing
to do than to ask people
to share their memories.
And I think people are
usually happy to do that
as long as you're not
going to dash off and just
focus on that.
And so I convinced
them with the promise
of telling the whole story.
And then you spend a
lot of time with them.
I've have three, four
hour conversations,
and I didn't get anything
until the fourth hour.
Usually the first-- when
I was interviewing people
about Tim Cook, for
example, for the first hour,
people are like, well,
Tim's a great boss.
I respect him a lot.
He's very driven.
He has high demands.
And then you probe for certain
stories, how he handled things,
and then you get the real story.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So suffice to
say Katie Cotton didn't send
you a note of congratulations
when the book came out.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: No, no.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD GINGRAS: Have you had
dealings with Apple since?
Are you off the invite list
for product [INAUDIBLE]?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Oh,
I was off the invite list
from the time that I began
working on this book.
They did have one, I guess,
momentary lapse in judgment
when they invited me to
their shareholders meeting.
But otherwise, I was
watching the video
feeds like everybody else.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So what
are you focusing on next?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Right now
I'm still promoting my book.
My Japanese launch of
the translated version
will publish in Japan
in a couple weeks.
And they're having
me over there.
So I'm preparing for that, and
still very much on this story.
But I am starting to think
about some other books,
and I'd eventually like
to write another book.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So the other
interesting thing about Apple,
of course, is the
fan boy culture.
Have you suffered at the
hands of the fan boy culture
since this book came out?
I mean you--
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
The short answer is yes.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
And exactly how?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
Well, the opinions
have been all over the spectrum.
Tim Cook-- I don't know
if some of you may know,
but Tim Cook
commented on my book,
basically on the afternoon of
the first day that the book--
AUDIENCE: On Amazon?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
No, I think he--
I had a CNBC interview
that morning,
and he was responding
to a CNBC reporter that
asked him for a comment.
But he said my
book was nonsense.
And I went out with
my own statement
because I was in an interview
with another reporter
at the time that the
comment came out,
which was a strange
sensation as a reporter.
But that unleashed all these
Apple fans who are like, yeah,
that's nonsense.
My book got
zero-bombed on Amazon.
So if you go to
Amazon, there's a lot
of-- there's one star
ratings and five star ratings
basically.
And they were happening
from the first day,
so before anybody really had
a chance to read the book.
I mean, it's what makes
covering Apple so interesting.
It's to be expected, and I think
it's one of Apple's greatest
strengths is that people are so
passionate about the company.
And so you can't
begrudge them that.
But one thing to watch is
to see how that changes,
or whether that changes
as the years go on.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
What did you think
of their recent announcements?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I
thought a couple of things.
I was shocked at
how much more muted
it was compared to some of the
WWDCs when Steve was there.
I was shocked that--
RICHARD GINGRAS: Muted in the
reaction, or muted in the--
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: In the
reaction and the excitement.
I was surprised that everything
was a pre-announcement.
One of the things that Steve
really felt strongly about
was that you announce things--
you don't announce things
until they're ready.
And then you capitalize on the
excitement by offering it up.
And everything was
a pre-announcement.
There wasn't a single
thing you could access.
I mean, there was
even one announcement
where they showed
something that wasn't going
to be available until next year,
which was just insane to me.
But in a different way,
a lot of the things
that Apple's been doing recently
has been really interesting
for me.
Because what I see is I
see Apple trying to evolve.
They're trying to move away
from what would Steve Jobs do.
I think, as I was writing
this book, one of the themes
that kept coming up and what
was obvious was Apple trying
to prove that nothing has
changed without Steve.
I mean, you saw that in
Tim Cook's statements.
He would say, we're
just as strong as ever.
Innovation continues
to be our North Star.
Nothing has changed.
And that wasn't
convincing to me.
Because everything has
changed without Steve.
And now I feel like
you're starting
to see Apple understanding that
and trying to move past it.
They didn't make it
as clear at WWDC,
but they are moving to a
new vision in the connected.
Home They're doing
different things.
The Beats acquisition.
I mean, for better
or for worse, it
was something probably
that Steve never
would have considered.
And so the question
to me, and what
will be most interesting
to me going forward,
is whether Apple's vision,
Apple's new vision,
and this new Apple, can
convince and inspire.
Because that was what
Apple was fueled on
for the last 15 years.
And so they can come up
with this grand vision,
but if people won't
come on board with it,
then it's not a good sign.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I
mean, you actually
seem to suggest that in some
of their recent announcements,
last six months or so,
that they're actually
almost explicitly
putting distance
between themselves and Steve.
A number of the
off-the-cuff references
with the introduction of
the new version of the iOS
of sort of pushing back
on real world metaphors
and so on and so forth, which
he was very much party to.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Yeah.
Yeah, with the new iOS, I
thought that was interesting
because it was
almost-- I think it's
one of the steps in
grieving, to lash out
at the person who's
no longer around.
And the comments that they
were making against the former
look and feel, where
it was just almost
overly done and unwarranted
because it was something that
had worked for them for so long.
So it deserved at least
some modicum of respect.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
what's your take--
it's been how long
since he died?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: It's
been two, almost three years.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Almost three years.
And we've heard these--
Tim Cook has almost
sounded like Al Gore in the
lockbox with his reference
to the North Star on a
very, very repetitive basis.
Eddy Cue comes out, who's--
these are good people.
I don't mean to sound critical.
Eddie Cue's a great guy.
I mean, these are really
solid, solid people.
He says, I think we've got the
greatest pipeline of products
that we've ever
had in our history.
But still nothing's
quite coming to the fore.
What's your take of this?
What are you hearing?
Is there something
around the corner,
or are they just vamping?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE:
I think-- well,
we know that they're working on
stuff, because we hear trickles
about it, about the
watch, the television.
I do hear enough
evidence from Asia
that there are real proposals
and real things going on.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Are
they being cautious
about-- because with
every new product launch,
there's some risk.
You don't know everything.
And is there some sort of
enhanced concern on their part
about the first new
thing they do post Steve
not being as super successful
as they feel it needs to be?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I
think caution is definitely
weighing in.
I mean, Tim Cook is much
more of a cautious executive.
I mean, there are no guarantees
with product launches.
But he wants as much-- he wants
all the I's dotted and the T's
crossed, and he wants to
be as sure as possible.
Because he knows that he's
got to hit a home run.
And I do you think--
I mean, you feel
the weight of the
pressure just mounting.
Every time they
miss an opportunity,
the expectations
grow just as much.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
And in a sense, you
could say-- I haven't really
thought about it that way,
but in a sense, you could
say that the longer more
time passes, the greater the
expectation that whatever they
do, as you say, has
to be a home run.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: I think
it's almost an impossible
situation for them
because they're such a--
when you think about it,
they're such a big company.
They're making $150 or $160
billion in revenues every year.
So how many watches
do they have to sell
to add 5% to their top
line or bottom line?
And then remember
that they're used
to profit margins of 30%, 40%.
And so how do you get
30%, 40%, from watches?
And then with
televisions, they're
used to products that people
will upgrade to every year.
I don't see a future
any world where
people are going to upgrade
their televisions every two
or three years, much
less every year.
And so the bar financially
for them to be successful
is higher as well.
And even though Apple's
going to keep making money
for a long time
to come, you have
to ask, how will they
prove their success?
What do they need to do
for their new product
to be successful?
And they will have to show
some sort of financial success.
And that's really
challenging, especially
when you consider that
Apple's first iPod wasn't
a blockbuster.
Apple's first iPhone wasn't.
It's the usually the
second generation
and later that really takes off.
And so the question
is, to me-- so the odds
are the first product is
going to still have kinks.
And it'll be interesting.
Hopefully, it'll be interesting.
But it's not going to
be enormous in terms
of financials.
And at that point,
what does Apple do?
I mean, Steve was the
guy who'd still push.
And he pushed harder.
But is Tim that guy,
or is he the guy
who's going to be cautious
and start pulling back,
even before the product has
had a chance to be successful?
And that'll be something that's
really interesting to see.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
it makes me wonder,
given A, their addiction
to high priced,
high margin products,
the fact that they really
haven't won in the cloud, is
it almost too much to ask?
Is it almost interesting to
ask the reverse question?
If Steve were still
alive, would they not
be still facing
these challenges,
and would their likelihood of
success necessarily be better?
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Yeah.
I think that Apple would have
faced a lot of these challenges
even if Steve were here.
He probably would have been
more successful at convincing
the world that these
challenges weren't
there for a while longer
than is apparent now.
And by the way, I think--
and part of Apple's challenge
is the competition around them.
And from a management
perspective, Steve was Apple,
and he was able to take risks
and make really bold decisions
in a way that nobody ever
will be able to again.
Because the board
worked for Steve.
And now going forward, the CEO
will be working for the board.
But when you look
at the competition,
you have Google, and Larry,
who's got that authority.
You've got Amazon
and Jeff Bezos.
You've got Facebook
and Mark Zuckerberg.
You've got Netflix
over there as well.
And all of these
companies have the ability
to make really bold decisions
and take much bigger risks
than Apple will because they
still have founder CEOs.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well, I
thank you very, very much.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Thank you.
RICHARD GINGRAS: This has
been a great conversation,
and a lot of good
food for thought.
Questions that are relevant,
I think, obviously to Google
as well, as we all
figure out, how
do we evolve a big corporation
and continue to be innovative.
So I thank you very
much for your work,
and I look forward
to your next efforts.
YUKARI IWATANI KANE: Thank you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]